nous attendions à une discussion il est
évident que ce sont des faits davis
à trancher dans la mesure où c'est un
débat qui reste technique maintenant
l'asm a été débouté pour une part mais
dans cette décision il ya des éléments
en terme de motivation d'implémentation
qui conforte malgré tout l'analyse
juridique que la sbe avait fait de cette
situation c'est à dire sur le fait que
mais cas de force majeure qui a été
soulevée par l'asm eux consistait
également à démontrer qu'elle avait mis
en oeuvre tous les moyens pour pouvoir
respecter ses obligations contractuelles
aujourd'hui il est demandé peut-être de
fournir davantage sur ses moyens les
moyens mis en oeuvre ne sont pas
contestées mais manifestement il
faudrait davantage insister et produire
des éléments sur ses moyens or sur ce
point alain semaine il n'y aura aucune
difficulté à les former dans cette
décision où il n'est pas temps indiqué
qu'elle aurait dû mettre en oeuvre des
moyens supplémentaires mais plutôt la
preuve rapporté de tous les moyens
qu'ils ont déjà été mises en oeuvre
il ya des éléments qui ont été fournis
maintenant la juridiction a considéré
qu'il aurait fallu lui en donner
d'autres pour pouvoir renforcer les
moyens que nous
présentant hors ces éléments là seront
et peuvent être remis sans aucune
difficulté c'est la raison pour laquelle
je vous dis que sur la discussion
juridiction a quand même pris donc
l'argumentation qui a été effectué le
temps il s'agit simplement des moyens de
preuve a étayé et c'est avec grand
plaisir que la société margot caisse des
eaux se chargera de le faire